So we're coming to the end of the course
and,
and uh,
the last couple of lectures,
last few social issues,
and then we'll have a very short time
for environment unfortunately. Um,
so today we're going to
talk about abortion and it's
kind of a unique topic in
the sense that in the United
States it's, it's uh, it's, it's,
if you have a global perspective
in most of the world,
abortion is not a big controversial
issue in the United States.
It's just going sky high as kind of the
central issue in the American debate on
values has tremendous
political significance.
Large numbers of people
vote for a candidate for say
president based solely on
whether they,
they approached choice or pro life.
So one of the things you got
to figure out or try to is,
is why has this become
so important an issue.
And I think one of the reasons is that
it encapsulates a diametrically opposed
views of our roles in everyday life.
If people perceive it as
an everyday kind of issue.
And what are the roles that I'm
talking about? Sex Roles, work roles,
husband and wife roles, motherhood
and fatherhood roles. All of those,
how you perceive yourself in those
roles will very much determine how you,
how you feel about the abortion debate.
So for instance, both sides in the debate
agreed that the issue is about murder.
Uh, a pro lifer sees images
of the three month old fetus,
which even though only about the size of
your finger and they see they're having
visuals of blown up photographs and
every year I'm sure you've all seen those
things and it already looks
quite baby like and thinks of it,
of being dismembered and murdered
approach.
Choicer also sees it about murder,
but she in her mind is a young
woman, maybe herself, uh,
in a back alley abortion being
butchered and possibly murdered.
And almost every one of
the older generation of,
of pro choice women has either themselves
had an abortion or have ha or has had
a friend who's had an abortion and they
perceived it as life saving or if it was
a back alley unsuccessful one
as life depriving situation.
Both sides agree that the issue
is about babies and motherhood.
Prolife mother thinks that babies are
so precious that whenever they come they
will be loved and wanted. There is no
such thing as an unloved or unwanted baby.
A pro choice mother thinks the babies
are so precious that they should only be
had when the woman really wants the baby
and it's a situation in life where they
have the resources to kick,
take care of the baby.
Both sides agree that
the issues about sex, uh,
prolife woman thinks that sexist,
so special that it should be guarded by
strong religious and social controls so
that it always has an
almost sacred character.
The pro choice woman thinks sex is so
special that it should be freed of worry
about pregnancy and disease so that it
can be enjoyed as a unique sharing of
intimacy.
Both sides agree that the issues about
the status of women prolife women think
that women are so important that they're
special life role of motherhood must be
protected.
Pro Choice.
Women think that women are so important
that they should have every bit as much
control over their lives.
Over their life roles as men have.
So just viewed in that way.
The,
the,
one of the interesting things about this
abortion debate is that the two sides,
and if you really get down to what the
fundamental values of the two sides are,
they don't, they're not different.
They apply them differently.
They were thinking of different instances
of different real situations in which
to apply these rather same kind
of fundamental human values.
All right,
well obviously this is not a philosophy
course and not in the slightest set up
to debate the pros and cons of abortion.
And that's also a kind of
sterile debate. Uh, anybody,
has anybody changed their mind about
abortion since they were the hydro
grasshopper in the class and when
know which direction you were,
one has changed her mind. Okay.
Two has changed in a, that's a,
that's high ratio.
Does anybody know anybody who's changed
their minds except for yourself?
Of course. One or two more
people, two or three, another one.
So, depending, I mean,
there's so much about abortion out there
and yet people's attitude toward it is
said very early in life by again,
these very fundamental images of what
we're talking about when we talk about
abortion.
And no matter how it's argued,
people basically don't
change their opinions. So,
uh, so I'm not going to debate
pros and cons, uh, at all.
I'm going to give you as
many facts about abortion as,
as I can explain to you the demography
in the biology, in the statistics and,
and all of that kind of stuff.
So there's a number of important things
that you should know about abortion.
And the first of it that it
induced abortion is common.
It's a very frequent
situation in the world.
There's one abortion for every
3.2 live births. So a very odd,
that's, that's one, two,
three, uh, each year,
about 3% of women in childbearing ages,
uh,
have an abortion.
And if you consider a 30 year reproductive
lifespan with each woman having a 3%
chance each year,
that's 90%.
That means that in the world,
uh,
the average woman has a 0.9
chance very close to one.
Basically for every woman in the
world, uh, there's one abortion,
uh, in, in, in the her
reproductive lifetime.
Of course, this is an average. Some women
have many more and some women have none.
There are three,
actually three or four standard ways of
measuring and expressing the frequency
of abortion.
Uh,
one is simply the number of abortions in
the world or in the country or whatever
you want. And the latest estimate, all of,
of the latest these lay Desmond come
from 2003 about every five years,
uh, people trying to tally up, uh,
abortion statistics from around the world.
And it's a very difficult job
because, uh, wherever it's illegal,
you're very great.
Difficulty getting statistics.
In many places they were,
especially with this religious
opposition to abortion, they, uh,
the statistics included
as menstrual regulation.
That means a woman has missed her MNCs.
And of course everyone knows
that's not a good thing.
So you have to restore the MNCs and
you do exactly what's in the abortion.
And everybody in the country
will understand what's going on.
But the statistic is menstrual regulation.
So depending on what's happening in
the country, usually have to add,
one part of the government says is
about minster regulation to another part
which says abortion.
Anyway,
there's lots of problems in in
collecting these numbers, but uh,
they're probably fairly decent cause they
very sophistic demographically very of
sophisticated people are the ones
that try to make these best estimates.
So the number of abortions in the world
is now considered to be 42 million per
year and the number has
stayed in that range.
The 40 to 50 million range for at least
the last two decades when there's fairly
good collection of this statistics.
So that's the number.
The abortion rate is defined as the
abortion spur a thousand women in
reproductive ages,
which is usually taken us 15 to
44 or 15 to 49 for the world.
It's 29 per thousand.
So every year per thousand women,
29 have had an abortion.
That's the 3% that I mentioned earlier.
If it was 30 it will be exactly 3%
both the highest rate and the
lowest rates are found in Europe.
Western Europe has 12 abortions
per thousand women per year.
Eastern Europe has four times as
many 44 per thousand women per year,
so it's interesting that the
whole world within Europe,
which we sometimes consider a cultural
entity, it isn't with respect to abortion,
the highest and lowest
numbers are found in Europe.
Another way of expressing
it as the abortion ratio,
which is the abortions
per hundred live births,
and that's what I told you before,
one abortion for every 3.2
live births in the world,
that comes out to 31 per 100 and this
ranges from a 12 and middle Africa.
It's, it's a, it's a low rate
to 105 in eastern Europe. Again,
Eastern Europe has the
highest in the world, no debt,
105 we're talking about
abortions per Leiper's.
When you have 105 abortions
per hundred live births,
there are more abortions than live births,
so a at a hundred a
hundred half of pregnancies
are terminated with an abortion.
Interestingly, the abortion
rate is the same, is very,
very closely the same
independent of whether you're
in a developing country or a
developed country.
The rate and developed countries is 26
per thousand and in developing countries
is 29 per thousand. Not A,
not a huge difference. Uh,
China,
which everyone worries about the forced
abortions there has about 20% of the
world's population and has about
20% of the world's abortions.
Another,
the last number that I'll tell you about
the people calculate is what's called
the total abortion rate,
which is calculated exactly in the
same way as the total fertility rate,
but you take the age specific
abortion rate and add it up,
and it's the number of abortions that
the average woman would have in her
lifetime if she continues with the
rates that are present at the time you
collect the statistics. And again, I
mentioned this in the world, it's 0.9,
very close to one. The average woman
will have one abortion in her lifetime.
It ranges from a low of 0.21
abortion per every five women,
uh, in several countries
to a high of 1.7 in Cuba,
almost two abortions per woman in Cuba.
Well,
I'll talk later about the very
interesting situation in Cuba.
So over time, uh, as I said,
the number of abortions is really on
the big scale of a couple of decades
staying pretty constant.
But from the last compilation in 1995,
the estimate was 46 million abortions and
now it's down to 42 million abortions.
So there's been a very small
drop in the number of abortions.
And where do you think all
that drop has occurred?
Eastern Europe and again,
they had an extremely high uh, abortion
rate. It was the meth mechanism,
the mechanism of contraception there and
they're gradually becoming accustomed
to contraception.
So their abortion rate is going down.
Three quarters of the change in the whole
world are all due to Eastern Europe.
The United States looks pretty much
like the rest of the world. Uh,
there, there's one abortion
for every 3.2 live births here,
which is exactly the number that
is the average for the world.
The United States or 1.3
million abortions. And again,
2003 the last time this
statistics collected,
uh,
there's, and the, the rate is
21.3 abortions per thousand woman.
If you look per woman,
the u s looks a little better than a pro
birth that the total abortion rate in
the United States is 0.64 per women.
That means two thirds of the average
is two thirds of women will have an
abortion during their lifetime,
whereas the world is closer to one.
So we have a somewhat lower
rate. And again, the, the, the,
the differences, the use of contraception,
and I'll talk about that later.
Uh,
the United States,
although somewhat better than the world
average in this is not nearly as good as
the point to remember. I said
ours is 0.64, uh, Belgium,
Germany and Switzerland
all are down at 0.2.
So less than a third of the number
of abortions per woman that we have,
uh,
so cohort of a thousand women going
through the reproductive life,
they'll have 639, uh, abortions.
And that's assuming we currently have
been having a reducing rate of abortion
here at presumes that
that rate will stay down.
So expanding out to the world again,
uh,
abortion can be a major
method of fertility control,
especially when a country first goes
through its fertility transition.
And one of the fastest fertility of
transitions in the world was in Japan.
Of all places where
they have the birthrate,
the birthrate in Japan was had
between 1947 in 1957 in 10 years,
went down to half from 34 per thousand
women to 17 and it's remained at that
level more or less until 1979
and now it's getting even lower.
And here is,
this is an interesting case of Japan,
so this is the years 49 member MacArthur,
the u s administration of Japan was still
sort of tailing down at that time and
we're looking at it at a 10 year span.
This is the number of pregnancies
which is births plus abortions.
And you'll notice that during this time,
during this tenure has been,
the number of pregnancies really
does not change an awful lot. No,
it's 20007002000 700900600 800800600
so the number of pregnancies does not
change,
but look what happens to abortion.
It gets legalized here and very rapidly,
it goes from a hundred to
up to 10 times as much.
Correspondingly,
the births go down.
So abortion goes from an insignificant
fraction of births to vary so much,
much closer to the number of births.
So in this case it was legalization of
abortion that sort of boom cause the,
the, the Japanese birth rate to
fall, there was no coercion involved.
It was purely a legalization step
in many places, places abortion
is the method of birth control.
So in the Soviet Union,
the official statistics before it fell
apart where that there were five to eight,
uh, abortions, lifetime per woman, uh,
in the Ukraine it was 10
to 12 abortions per woman.
The immigrants that come to America
say that's nonsense that uh,
it was 20 to 30 that everybody they
know have 20 to 30 abortions lifetime.
Japan also because of though they
legalized abortion very early.
They didn't legalize the pill until
just a couple of few years ago and they
legalize it when Viagra came out
and the men demanded to get Viagara.
They are very good national health plan.
It's all free.
And very careful and very good.
And men wanted free Viagara and then it
became politically impossible to keep
women from having the, but
pay for, for men's Viagara.
So Japan legalized it, uh, very recently.
The pill and via their abortion
rate has always been extremely high.
Um,
in some special circumstances,
uh,
the abortion rates are sky high.
So in 1966 in Romania,
there were 408 abortions for every hundred
live births for abortions for every
one live birth.
And the history of that is very,
very interesting. Uh, in
the whole Soviet block,
cause it was a complex of issues.
Uh, contraception was legal,
it was kind of available,
but the manufacturing was terrible.
So they had condoms in the
various Soviet bloc countries,
but there are so poorly made that the
people called them galoshes. They just,
they just didn't fit. Plus,
uh, the doctors were, were,
uh, working for the government
and not paid very well,
but they could privately outside
the government statistics,
they could privately do
abortions and make money on it.
So the doctors role pushing abortion
and a variety of other reasons. We'll,
we'll talk more about countries in which
abortion is by far the dominant means
of birth control.
Okay.
Legally legal and medically performed
abortion by a trained doctor is one of the
safest methods of birth control.
No.
And here is the statistics on this.
This is from the,
you know,
the physician's desk reference for for
many years all of the birth control pills
have to have this graph in it.
And what do you see here?
This is the annual deaths,
uh,
of for women per 100,000 non sterile
women who are either using or not using
birth control.
What you noticed the really high category
was the only super duper high is women
over 40 who smoke.
Then I did,
oh and use the pill smoking use depot,
that's pill.
The pill is their method of
contraception and they smoke.
If you're over 40 and you smoke,
don't use the pill.
That's not a healthy thing to do
for every other category of woman.
The white bars are larger
than any of the other bars.
And the white bar is not
using contraception at all.
And what this tells you is if
they're not using contraception,
they're going to get pregnant. And that
the mortality dangerous, this is death.
So this is mortality.
But the mortality dangers from pregnancy
are a good bit higher than any of the
other methods of birth control.
What,
what year was this one?
This is,
um,
I think about 1990 and hasn't,
well,
what has changed is that,
let me finish and I'll tell
you what's changed since then.
So the safest is these little black bars,
which can hardly see,
which is traditional contraception,
which is condoms, what they're
talking about, backed up by abortion.
That is the safest of all of all methods.
And then the other methods
like a diaphragm and condom,
uh, Rud, uh,
pills and pills for
nonsmokers abortion only, uh,
are all sort of low but intermediate.
So the story is,
with the exception of
older women who smoke,
the worst thing you can do is not use
any method that that's, that's dangerous.
The best thing you can do is use
a condom backed up by abortion.
That's surprising cause there's so
much popular myth out there, uh,
that,
that misconstrues these facts.
Now what has changed is that this data
was taken in the earlier days of birth
control pills, which were high dose.
You've probably heard about this.
They used to have very high dose
because they were, it was new,
they didn't know about it and they
wanted to be sure the main thing was to
prevent pregnancy.
Then they realize they could get away
with lower and lower doses and the pills
nowadays have much lower doses.
So they're much less side effects.
So all of these columns
will probably be way,
way down from what they
were. So and, and yeah,
that's, that's what's,
that's what's changed. Um,
when you go to the developing
world, uh, this is,
this is United States data. When you
go to the developing world, of course,
pregnancy itself is much more dangerous.
Childbirth is much more dangerous.
So what you see is these white bars
go awful lot higher depending on the
country. If you're in the middle of
Africa, they're very high. If you're in
other places, they're pretty much
like the United States level.
Both, both, both, all of the above. Um,
okay.
Not only,
so this just shows you immediate
mortality and it's clear what's going on.
Um,
abortion apparently has no longterm
clinical effects whatsoever.
There's no physical effects. It, again,
we're talking about proper medically
done abortion, sterile abortions, uh,
properly done.
They're no long term clinical effects,
neither physical nor psychiatric there.
It doesn't make a women sterile.
It doesn't increase the
chance of sterility and it
doesn't cause you to go crazy
later. None of that stuff is
statistically true. Of course,
there are women who either having
an abortion, not having an abortion,
go through all these bad events,
but statistically they're the same.
The number of women have had an abortion
and eventually go sterile will be the
same as those who have not had an
abortion and eventually go sterile.
Now that's a medical sequelae.
What the emotional content
of having an abortion?
That varies tremendously depending.
It varies tremendously by country.
We'll talk about some countries where
it's an absolutely like a nonevent having
an abortion and other,
other places.
And other individuals
where if their own ethics,
their own morality, their own
desire for a child, their religion,
if it really is opposed to abortion,
then there can be a lot of
emotional difficulty with it.
But that's not, uh, a thing to
do with the abortion itself.
It's to do with the,
so we say the moral context in which
that woman perceives the abortion to have
been done long with this. Um,
the, so you have these generally quite
high rates of abortion around the world.
And the question is what are
the determinants of that? Right?
What makes the rate higher?
What makes the rate lower? Uh,
many people believe that religious
prescription that the religions,
religion of the country is what is
the determining factor. But it's not,
uh, it's for instance, in
Europe, among Catholic countries,
Belgium has one of the
lowest rates in the world.
A 6.8 per thousand and Hungary and other
Catholic country has one of the highest
34.7 per thousand. So your, your span,
the whole range among Muslim countries,
Bangladesh is one of the lowest rates.
A 3.8 wild Turkey has six
or seven times that rate.
And again, the Bangladesh rate is
a little confused because of the,
they use a lot of
menstrual regulation there.
The U s largely been, certainly
not exclusively Protestant country,
has about the same rate as Turkey.
So which is a strick is essentially
all Muslim. Of course, uh,
people believe that,
uh,
the Catholic Church of course teaches that
abortion is a mortal sin. It's murder.
But in the u s the abortion
rate for protestants,
which has 17 per thousand is lower
than for Catholics, 24 per thousand.
And as far as one can tell,
Catholics because of church becomes
slightly under use birth control.
So as a compensation they
slightly, uh, overuse abortion.
Uh,
the,
the error bars and all these basically
mean that there's barely detectable
difference between say Protestants and
Catholics within America, within one,
any one country. Uh, so there's two,
two issues of why the
Catholic rate is higher. Yeah,
this is per thousand.
Those are numbers per thousand per
thousand women of reproductive age,
not per thousand babies. So, uh,
the kind of a thing is most is,
most of the difference in that statistic
is that there's a large Hispanic
population in America,
which happens to be Catholic and as a
higher abortion rate than native born
women. So that is the most of the
reason why the Catholic rate is higher.
It's also,
you can't tie it down to a
legal prescription whether
abortion is legal or not
legal. You can't tie that down as a
determining factor in abortion either.
About half of the abortions in
the world are illegal and the old,
it's the old statistics
use the word illegal.
But now there is such a variety of,
of legal rules and that was such a variety
of situations in each country where,
where it's legal or not. And now
different states and different cards,
like in Mexico,
Mexico City has one law in each
state can have a very different laws.
So it gets to be very
difficult to describe legality.
And that's all tied in with with safety,
which we'll come back to.
And you'll see to six about safe abortion
sometimes says about legal abortion
and they're usually,
they fit right on top of each other.
So about half of the abortions
in the world are illegal,
the other half are illegal.
Um,
so for instance,
in Europe,
abortionist is generally legal everywhere
under a very wide range of conditions.
It's abortion rate is 28,
uh,
per thousand in Africa where it's
illegal almost everywhere. Uh,
it's 29. So again, uh, no, no difference.
The lowest rates in the world or
in western and northern Europe were
abortionists accessible with
few restrictions. So the total,
basically the total legality of abortion
is in a place where the rates are very
low.
Up to 2007,
abortion was banned in Mexico, so it was
totally illegal everywhere in Mexico.
Nevertheless,
uh,
the number of abortions rose
by 50% between 1,990 and
2006 with a constant legal
situation of illegality.
And in 2006,
Mexico's abortion rate was 40% higher
than the u s rate, uh, next door.
And so here you have three countries
that are on the line. Canada,
the US and Mexico.
Canada has a much lower in the United
States is in the middle and Mexico and
those two are legal in
Mexico. It's illegal and it
has the highest rate of all.
So,
but of course,
I should warn you and probably
realize that that saying that,
that uh, abortion doesn't,
he can't use that.
The legal thing is not the
determining factor. These,
these intercontinent comparisons from
your country comparisons are not terribly
informative because so many between say
Mexico and the United States in between
Africa and Europe, there are
so many variables, so many
socioeconomic variables,
education, medical care, standard of
living. All of this varies tremendously.
And the difference in abortion rates is
not to be found in the legal or illegal
nature of it, but in some of
those other characteristics.
Okay. Uh, in most countries,
abortion is legal.
And as of a few years ago,
61% of the world's people lived in
countries where abortion is permitted,
uh,
basically without restriction or
in a wide range of, of reasons.
Only 25% live in places where
abortion is largely illegal.
These are largely Latin America,
some of the Muslim countries in
sub Saharan African countries,
abortion is becoming a
legal in more places. Uh,
from 1985 to 98,
19 nations significantly liberalized their
abortion laws and only Poland Dee Dee
legalized
abortion,
which had to do with its independence
basically from the Soviet Union.
At the time there was 85 to 98.
From 98 to 2007. Again, the latest data,
16 nations liberalized their abortion
laws and two territories in one state in
Australia liberalized its
abortion laws. And, uh,
in Mexico I mentioned Mexico or Mexico
City has now made abortion in the first
12 weeks, uh, legal and
that was in 19. In 2007,
I believe. And then a few states
and Mexico has followed that.
So Mexico is now split, uh, place, uh,
in this, uh, 98 to 2007 timeframe, uh,
El Salvador and Nicaragua,
which already had a very restrictive
abortion laws when to absolute under no
circumstances abortions,
totally no, no rape, no death,
health of the mother and no exceptions
in Nicaragua and El Salvador.
In contrast to the safety
of legal abortion where
abortions are when it's legal,
it's almost always done.
Proper medical situation. Uh,
when it's illegal, it's an
extremely dangerous procedure. Uh,
there's,
I'm like 67,000 abortion related
deaths a year and that leaves 220,000,
a quarter million children, uh,
without their mothers. As you may know,
when it's illegal,
the main procedure is inserting something
up the uterus and scraping around to
try to dislodge the, the, the
endometrium and, and, and the, um,
and the fetus.
Well,
if you're scraping around in there with
a pointed stick or a hanger or something,
you're liable to puncture of the uterine
wall and make a hole between the inside
of the uterus,
which is open through the vaginal canal
to the outside and the peritoneal cavity,
the inside of your body.
And so infection gets through that.
And so the main route isn't
the main reason why abortion,
illegal abortion is so dangerous,
is that non sterility of whatever
it is that's inserted a plus,
it's pointed usually,
and the break right through
the uterine wall. In addition,
you may know that the flow Pian tube is
open into the peritoneal cavity because
the, uh, the ovary, which
releases the egg is,
is it sits right on top of the Fallopian
Tube and the egg is released into the
peritoneal space just
to the body fluid here.
And it's supposed to drop down into the
Fallopian tube and Cilia push it down.
But that's an opening.
So if you get something unsterile in,
into the womb and then the bacteria can
swim upstream and you're into the body
and then you to antisepsis
and you very likely die.
Um, so, uh, it's, uh,
it's a very dangerous
procedure when done, uh, not,
not properly. Um, the,
the very good statistics,
uh,
showing that the main determinant of
the maternal death rate from abortion is
legal status. So I think I
have this. So here again, no,
I don't think I showed
this slide. So here is, uh,
places where abortion is legal.
Here's the abortion rate. This goes,
it goes back to saying that the legal
situation doesn't determine the rate of
abortion here. Various, uh, uh,
abortion legal places and the rate is
about six to 26 and here it's illegal.
Uh, and he had the range
of 23 to 52, so, you know,
ballpark double or triple
this, right, so it's illegal.
These are all South America.
This is all Europe,
Japan, Australia, United States,
very developed countries,
countries that are partially developed,
shall we say.
So the legality correlates with the,
the, the abortion rate, but it's
almost certainly not the cause.
Certainly being illegal is not
causing these high abortion rates.
But now when you go over and
look at the maternal deaths,
you see that there are there 10,
the developed regions
have an average of 10,
whereas in Latin America you have up in
102 hundred and even up to 300 range.
You go to Africa, 650. So they are,
the illegality really does make a
difference in the maternal death rate.
That's, that's the dominant effect of, of,
of making something illegal is,
doesn't change the abortion rate.
We have a number of examples,
but it changes the maternal death rate
very,
very clearly.
The most extreme example of this,
and the clearest example of this
is us from Romania. Romania had,
uh, uh, during,
after World War Two when it
was a Soviet puppet state, uh,
as I told you, the abortion
rate was extraordinarily high,
like four abortions for every
one live birth. And because the,
the, the, the, well,
they had a dictator then Nick Nicolae
Ceausescu who you undoubtedly have heard
of, and he decided that for
the glory of Greater Romania,
there should be more Romanians.
He wanted a big, strong state.
So he went on a pro natalist campaign.
Uh,
abortion was immediately
criminalized. Um, uh,
contraceptives became very hard to get.
They wouldn't import them,
they didn't manufacture them.
Uh,
so what he did is that all women between
18 and 45 were rounded up at their
workplace. Remember this? A socialist
state, so almost all the women worked.
They're rounded up at their workplace
and subjected to a gynecological
examination. And if they were not
pregnant, they had to explain to the,
to the, to the government
why they were not pregnant.
So it was about as intrusive
a pro natalist campaign.
As you can imagine, it's, it's somewhat
the mirror image of China's Eh,
anti birth campaign.
Romania had the blessed campaign
anyway. Uh, what happened immediately? Uh,
so previously 80% of
pregnancies had been ending.
It had been terminated with abortion,
abortion disappears and it was legal.
Abortion had been legal and boom,
the birth rate does indeed go up.
Nothing like by a factor of five,
but something like a factor of two as our,
as I remember.
But I want you to check that. Um, and,
but then very rapidly women's set up
networks of illegal abortion providers and
the birth rate goes up and the,
and the birth rate comes back down and
an ends up somewhat higher than it had
been beforehand,
but not enormously higher.
But the maternal death rate is,
is what changed.
It rose a to 200 per 100,000
live birth from, from a,
a number in a developed country. You
know, something in the tens or twenties,
it range to 10 times that amount.
The infant mortality rate because there's
mothers didn't want these children.
Presumably the infant mortality rate,
uh,
rose to 83 deaths per thousand from uh,
like uh,
Chapin's rate is 4.8.
The U S is 8.9 so it rose to 83.
So and again something like a 10
times increase in infant mortality.
So the main effect of d
legalizing abortion was a
temporary rise in the number
of births, but a long term increase
in maternal mortality and infant.
We're talking massive,
massive increase when by the time abortion
abortion of course when they got a
free of the dictator
it was legalized again.
And then by that time things have come
back a little normal but still the
maternal death rate,
as soon as they legalized abortion,
the maternal death rate
dropped by a factor of three.
So that's Romania is one example.
In South Africa,
you route more recently, this was in the
late sixties, the remaining his story.
And in South Africa the abortion law
was liberalized and the incidents of
maternal infection boot abortion dropped
dropped in half. So in all cases,
uh,
the major effect of making abortion
illegal is an increase in complications of
abort.
You don't change the abortion rate,
but complicated medical complications,
death of the mother, death of the infants,
the fundamental cause I would have been
going through things that are not the
cause of the high abortion rates.
It's not the religion that's not the
legality. The fundamental causes.
A kind of obvious is unintended pregnancy.
And you may remember that these, they're
very high rates of unintended pregnancy.
Oh, here is a comparison
of two regions, uh,
almost all legal in the developed
countries and in almost all of Africa it's
illegal. And the death rates an
enormous, enormous difference there.
So you may remember these statistics
just just to refresh your memory about
unwanted, uh, fertility.
So this is 71% of living.
Women want to stop having children.
Yet as I showed you before, they,
they have more,
they,
they continue to have children because
they're not using contraception.
They don't have enough contraception.
And here are around, that's Bolivia.
And this is from previous lecture
around the world. Remember,
this is the line where people,
this is how many children people are
having. This is how many they want.
This is the line where they're equal.
All countries,
all developing countries are having
more children that they want.
So there's a large amount of unmet unmet
need in the world and the estimate for
the world's 108 million, uh, women. Uh,
and these,
since there's an unmet need,
these women who don't want
to have more children,
he had do that results in some 51
million unintended pregnancies.
And of those using contraceptive,
another 25 million happened as a result
of incorrect or inconsistent use of
contraception or method failure.
So you have something like 80
million unwanted pregnancies
in the, the world is 210
million pregnancies annually.
And about 40% of them are unplanned.
And about a quarter of an,
we know from a lot of places that
when there's an unplanned pregnancy,
about a quarter of them end
in abortion. So the main, uh,
sequence is unwanted pregnancy
and then hi abortion rate.
And uh,
most most unintended
pregnancies in the world, uh,
well most unintend print
in the developed countries.
So there's difference here between
developed and undeveloped countries.
Contraception is,
is very available and in highly
used in the developed world.
So in the developed world,
most unintended pregnancies are of people
who are using contraception and using
it fairly accurately.
But there's a method,
a failure that the
contraception just just fails.
And you have to remember that a woman
is fertile for say 30 years of her life
and she has 12 sites,
12 monthly cycles in a year,
a little bit more actually because
the cycle is 20 days and principle.
But that's close enough.
And so in order to,
to not have an unintended pregnancy,
her contraception must be
law be perfect for 30 years,
12 cycles a year. That's an awful
lot to expect of the contraceptive.
And just contraceptives, you
know, or just not, not that good.
So in developed countries also,
uh,
the main reason for unintended pregnancy,
it's very heavily, it's married
women who are using contraception.
They usually have several children
already and the contraception fails.
That's, that's the main
reason in developed countries,
in developing countries where
contraception uses is less prevalent.
The main reason is not
non use of contraception,
the very strong relationship between
contraception and abortion. So,
so we have a country, most country
in the world with this unmet need,
women before you start
collecting statistics,
want fewer children than they're
having. Uh, but it's not a big deal.
Then something changes
could be an economic,
we've discussed the reasons of cultural
change and economic change, whatever.
And people really start
wanting to have fewer children.
So this happened around 1964 in
Korea. And you read, you know,
I gave you one of the stories about an
example of how this happens in Korea.
And what happens is,
as women,
as the whole culture changes from
wanting the sort of a maximum rate of
fertility to wanting a lower rate
of fertility, the contraception,
the abortion rate picks up first.
Because in all these countries,
abortion is a traditional method.
The women know it and are
moderately comfortable with it.
So you see first the abortion rate
starts going up. Then with a short lag,
the contraception rate goes up.
It goes all the countries establish
a national family planning programs.
And what happens as people
use more abortion news,
Morgan's contraception,
so they're reducing their fertility,
but the rate of drop of desired fertility
can be so fast that that even the
psalm of contraception,
abortion can't keep up with
it. So both rates keep rising.
Eventually you peak where abortion
peaks and starts falling down.
Contraception continues onward.
So this is the time when the demand to
have less fertility is more than either
method alone can cope with,
but eventually women and abortion
is easier cause the post,
it's a, it's an after
the fact, uh, method.
But eventually women learn
to use contraception views,
learn to use it and use you
learned to use it properly.
And so then the abortion rate declines
as the contraception rate continues on up
to very high levels.
Most of the difference here is women
who want to get get pregnant, something.
So you have this trade off,
you have an early stage,
both of them rise together and her later
stage they do very divergent things and
you'll see, uh, when you've got a
Prelim polemicizing discussion of this,
what you hear is that right
to life people say, oh,
contraception is no good abortion
rises with contraception.
And they use statistics
from this half and half.
People who are pro choice say no, no,
no or pro contraception. No, no, no.
It goes this way and they
use this half of the graph.
But you get both of these things.
And Korea is one example.
Here is another example of
the relationship between
contraception and abortion
in Bangladesh.
So here is member Mont Lob
where you read about my lab,
where they chose some villages and got
a very strong family planning program.
And then other villages where they
left alone as a control region.
They had family panic because
it had the government program.
The government program wasn't any near
as good as the intervention program.
So here's the control region and a lot,
a lot to see here. So first of all,
this is desired fertility and that starts,
uh,
at this level and drops down to somewhat
more than half desired fertility in the
Matlab region that was started about
the same level and falls about the same
amount. So the difference in the
terrain is not desired fertility.
The actual fertility rate drops here,
starts higher and drops a little faster
here. So that ends up not very different.
So again, the difference is not
the actual amount of fertility,
which the number of births
is an enormously difference
between the two regions.
But in the MOD law, in the,
uh, the experimental region,
the region where they
had the good program,
the contraceptive prevalence
goes very high. It goes rapidly,
very high from something like
30% more than doubles to 70%.
Whereas in the other
read the non girl region,
you have it starts much lower it,
it's, this rises very rapidly.
This doesn't change at
all for a number of years.
Then the government actually the
government improves its programming,
jumps up a little bit, it jumps up a
little bit. So it's the contraceptive.
This is a really big difference.
The contraceptive prevalence is much
lower in the control region then in the
experimental region. And the result
is here's the abortion ratio, uh,
in the region where the contraceptive
prevalence is very high.
And here the abortion ratio goes
crazy where they don't have,
they're not using contraception,
uh, efficiently. And again,
here you can see in those two regions,
the same country,
same time neighboring villages,
neighboring districts, uh,
that the, the, there's this trade off.
They either use contraception or
they was abortion in both places.
They're wanting fewer
children as time goes on.
But in one case they use contraception,
you know, the case, the use abortion.
Um, I think too, I have
another guy from that.
Here's another example of this
rather different in Shanghai,
and this is a more complicated,
somewhat interesting case.
This is the one child policy comes in.
They're only allowed one child.
So they have that child and then they
try to do something to avoid the second
child.
And what they use is a contraceptive
methods and they don't work.
They start with very high. Uh,
let me get this straight here.
Uh,
they start with a low use of Iud,
which is a really secure
method of contraception and
the abortion rate is very
high and they rather rapidly learn
that IUD only really secure way of not
getting pregnant and then
the abortion rate falls down.
So it's another rather different
situation in which again,
the abortion rate in the contrast
and the effect of constants,
contraceptive rate are
mirror images of each other.
When you have a high high rate
of effective contraception,
you have a low rate of abortion.
So,
uh,
so Latin America shows the same pattern,
in Latin America,
abortion has been practiced for centuries.
It a certainly practice by,
by the Incas and the Aztecs in 1551,
the bishop of Venezuela reported to the
King of Spain that the natives did not
want their children to become
slaves. So they boarded them. 1551,
Chile has very good medical statistics
at the beginning of chilies,
uh, fertility transition in the 1960s, uh,
23% of Chilean women voluntarily
admitted to having an, uh,
an induced abortion. Again, remember,
Chile is very heavily Catholic country
and this is not really delving into
medical records and making any cracking.
Just asking them whenever you had an
abortion. And a quarter of them say, yes,
I've had had an abortion.
And not only did they have an abortion,
but most of them had more than
one abortion. Up to three,
8.4% of the women had
more than seven abortions.
This is,
this is early on,
uh,
10 years later in the 70s.
Now it's, we're women, uh,
are really into their fertility decline.
They don't want the children. Uh,
the average woman has almost
three abortions, uh, lifetime.
So that that goes up.
And again,
those are the openly admitted numbers
and the real numbers must have been much
higher. And again, in
elsewhere, uh, in, in Chile,
almost all the women were married,
almost all middle class women and they
already had had four to six pregnancies
and they already had children and good
an experience with pregnancy in terms of
socioeconomic levels.
Middle class women had more abortions
than working class women married women had
a greater abortion rate than
those living in temporary unions,
just casual unions. And in all
through all of this time, uh,
abortion was completely illegal and
Chilean and it's still, uh, it's still is
going next door to lean to Peru,
uh,
in Lima in the 1970s, again, the time
when the fertility rate was going down,
when people were wanting
fewer children in Peru,
the yearly increase in the
abortion rate was 24% every year.
And there's 24% increase in abortion.
And in any given year,
a quarter to a third of the reproductive
age women would have abortions.
It's one out of four.
One out of three women every
year would have an an abortion.
Uh,
again, it's in this, the, the,
the really high abortion rates
or when women are sort of,
families are starting to want
fewer children and haven't
yet really figured out
how to use contraception.
Uh,
in Contemporary Latin
America, uh, abortion,
although it's illegal almost everywhere
and it's almost universally a catholic
place. Uh, abortion is
very widespread. Uh,
Latin Americans as a whole has one
abortion for every two live births.
Remember worldwide and
the U S it's one per 3.2.
Latin America has one
for every two live births
and eventually there's a generational
change and the younger women start using
contraception and then the
abortion rate starts to fall.
Oh, okay. Oh,
the Philippines and other example.
MMM.
Maybe. So in the Philippines, uh,
have a very interesting situation
of the politics. There's a,
there's a strong interrelationship
between the politics of the country, uh,
the Catholic Church and the
citizens use of, of contraception.
And when Ferdinand Fidel
Ramos was president,
one of the early very populous presidents,
he supported family planning and a
quarter of the Filipino women were using a
modern method.
And since then,
the desired fertility has gone
down in, in, in the Philippines.
And now more than half of Filipino
women want some form of birth control.
But the presidency has changed.
And a woman of Gloria or royal mockup,
a girl came in and since,
uh,
Ferdinand Marcos was a strong dictator
and they had strong presidencies,
but then when he was kicked
out for massive corruption, uh,
uh,
and,
and dictatorial means they now have
democratic elections and the governments
have been quite weak.
They don't have much popular support.
And so the government needs to get
legitimacy from somewhere. And this Cape,
they get legitimacy from the Catholic
Church because they're the Philippines,
very Catholic country.
And so I'm fairly open deal was
made between mockup a gall and, um,
and the,
the Archbishop of,
of the Philippines that the church will
support you if you make abortion illegal
and, and get rid of the
family planning programs.
And so now the government and that
was taken and she got elected.
And now the government, uh, uh,
only supports traditional family planning
methods, which is withdrawal basically.
Uh, and so, and this had an effect.
So from like 93 to 98 and a five,
six year period,
the use of traditional methods went up
by 50%. Well, the use of modern methods,
uh, didn't actually didn't change much,
but when the government pushes something,
it often goes up.
And all of those women,
the traditional methods just
plain don't work. So there,
so the result was that the number of
abortions in Philippines in the easiest
increased, uh, by 19% from
400,000 was already high,
from 400,000 went up to basically
a half a million abortions,
and they're all illegal. Of course. Okay.
As I said in the beginning,
in America,
abortion is a great source of controversy.
This is not,
uh, not always the case.
So in a lot of places, so,
uh,
there's,
there's a lot of literature now on
with called the culture of abortion.
Those countries for whom abortion
has the noncontroversial, uh,
uh, noncontroversial place as
a mechanism of fertility crow,
just as contraception has a more or
less noncontroversial place as a form of
fertility control and say,
Europe and America. So,
uh, I got invited to a few years back to
talk to the women's health class about
abortion. And uh, it was one of the
things we've talked about. And uh,
afterwards I was talking
with some students and a
professor with the next class
walks in and he turned out to
be from Russia and he asked us,
you know, what are you're talking
about? And the students had,
they started asking me questions about
something about abortion and he was
really puzzled. He said, abortion,
why is anybody interested in math?
Because in Russia,
just an ordinary,
absolute ordinary kind
of thing in like Romania.
And I'm sure this is to some degree
true and probably the whole East Eastern
Europe,
you remember I mentioned to you the
old theory that the health of the body,
it depends on the humors of that.
You've got the four humors and bio
and collar and all this and stuff.
And it's the balance that's important
and you have to reestablish and what the
menstrual period does. Everyone knows
the worst fluid is fee, menstrual fluid.
And so you've got to get rid of that.
And if you don't,
if you're not periodically getting rid
of menstrual fluid, the bad spirits,
humors, fluids build up in
you and you get unhealthy.
So in places like Romania,
many people older,
less educated people believe that it's
good to have an abortion every so often
having nothing to do with pregnancy
even, which is good to do that, to,
to get rid of this evil humor.
And that has persisted as well as
a lot of other really unbelievable,
almost unbelievable to us medical myths.
And as part of the reason for that very,
very high abortion rate in Romania
and the Ukraine, when the
Soviet Union fell apart, uh,
the family planning programs
that they had also fell apart.
And so the whole area was left without
effective family planning and the
International Planned
Parenthood Federation, the
nearest office was in Bangkok.
And so they couldn't,
they couldn't help very much.
And what they did is they said,
okay,
we'll take just the city of Moscow
cause it's most cost effective to,
to work in a city with a lot of people.
You don't have geographic issues.
And we'll try to provide
some contraception in Moscow,
but that left all the other Soviet
bloc countries with nothing.
And the Planned Parenthood
Federation of Connecticut here,
I was associated with them at the
time. Uh, con contact with the Ukraine.
The only crane was like lefty raft of
kind of separate and gut [inaudible] got
in touch with the, the main, uh, the
head in the university, uh, in Kev, the,
the head of the Ob Gyn Department
of very nice woman and uh,
started to help her provide, uh, you know,
just by contraceptives here in ship,
my broad,
actually we buy them internationally
very cheap. A cycle of pills is 80 cents.
In the world market.
A condom is like a penny and a half.
A diaphragm has to dollar
dollar and a quarter.
So if you buying them United States,
they're expensive, you buy them in India,
wherever they're made,
things are a lot cheaper.
So we can really help Ukraine a lot.
What they wanted first was cause you
can't use any of these things if this
pelvic infections.
So they wanted a monistat and
other treatments for pell,
for a vaginal infections as a,
as a first line,
and then they could start dealing
with contraception. So Anyway, um,
this program went on but
it wasn't very successful.
And the reason was the women were
using abortion and quite happy with it.
They didn't see anything wrong with it.
They were used to it and no problems.
So why should we change?
And so one of the things that,
that they did and we
helped them was we got, uh,
some of these rights to life films,
which show in the glorious way,
the way you know, the foot the fetus
looks like and what an abortion is like.
And you really are way,
way off the deep end and ship them to
them so they could show their patients
that you see in is not just this
sort of nothing, uh, kind of event.
The most interesting case might be Cuba,
which has, uh, one of the highest
abortion rates in the world,
78 per thousand women per year compared
to Canada, which is 15 and a half,
for instance.
Again,
that's the two sides of the United States
and almost 60% of what they call known
pregnancies are terminated by abortion.
So they have a long history.
Before 1938,
they were very much tied
culturally to Spain. And Spain
was very, uh, conservative.
That was Franco, uh, era of
very, very right wing fascist,
a catholic dictatorship. And
so all in, in the Spanish law,
all forms of abortion, uh,
induced abortion were illegal.
And Cuba just use that,
that same law,
uh,
in 30 and it was up til 1938 and 38 they
liberalized a little bit for a rape,
uh,
likelihood of death of the mother
or severe fetal malformation, uh,
issues.
But despite these restrictions that it
was the mechanism of birth control in
Cuba, and it was used widely by
all the social classes. Well,
I'll tell you an exception
to that, uh, by poor people.
And it was used in the cities and in the
countryside. So, so abortion was, it.
Contraception starts coming in,
but it's a foreign product and it's
expensive and you need some medical
knowledge to use it. So only
the upperclass uses, uh,
contraception at this time,
used contraception in, in Cuba.
And at that time, very, very, you know,
a few people owned all the sugar
plantations in everyone else's,
basically a slave on
the sugar plantations.
So the social gulf between the rich people
are using contraception and the poor
people using abortion was enormous
and they didn't talk to each other.
So there was no social diffusion of the
ideas of contraception so that people
just continued using contraception.
1959,
Fidel Castro has this
revolution and he takes over.
And in the beginning he's
antiabortion and he still is.
Uh, and, and a lot of events happen that
I'm simplifying a complicated history,
but in 1962, the United States
places in the Margo on Cuba,
including medical supplies.
And guess what?
The Cubans can't get contraception
because the United States was there.
Their sources supply. So abortion
gets, gets more entrenched.
The embargo might have done the biggest
thing to raise Cuban abortion rates.
No one has good statistics on that.
So,
uh, well, abortion is legal in Cuba.
The government really wants to,
uh, reduce it. Castro, ninth, 1998,
the pope visited Cuba as you probably
nay remember from all the headlines.
And he talked against abortion.
And shortly after that,
Castro gave a seven hour
lecture worse than me,
a seven hour lecture condemning
abortion as a method of birth control.
And he said it was his duty as a public
figure and the revolutionary leader to
oppose widespread abortion
but didn't have any effect on the people.
And it's very interesting. They've,
they've,
there's now a wonderful article in which
actually should have assigned to you,
um,
about what's going on in Cuba,
but you have too much
reading already. And so, uh,
the medical is the government in the
medical establishment want to get people
wean people off abortion.
And so in these interviews,
one of the things they ask the respondents
were women of all ages and men of all
ages. Uh, well,
what have you heard from doctors
and healthcare professionals? Well,
that it's dangerous that you can
die from it, but just a man that's,
that's what she's heard from the festival.
But just imagine if you had to give
birth every time you got pregnant.
I got pregnant, had an abortion when I
was 15, even though I was on the pill.
I also got pregnant earlier
when I was using an Iud.
This is a woman who at the time of
the injury was age 30 and she had,
this was after her fourth abortion.
And so the people's perception is very
different than what they're hearing from
the medical establishment and
the government establishment.
It's an absolutely an unremarkable
subject for discussion.
One male who is now age 49
said I was about 10 years.
You know, they ask you what have you
have you do hear about abortion as it is?
It discussed it and he says, uh, sure.
I was about 10 years old.
I heard about abortion from people
on the street also in my house.
My mom talked about it with
their friends in front of me. Uh,
another respondent around the streets.
Abortion is a common thing people
talk about. It's an everyday thing.
A male age 23.
Um,
do you know the, the tumor, do
you know anyone in your family?
Among your friends who's had an
abortion? Yes. And the antique mine.
What did she tell you that you don't
feel anything that they give you the
anesthetic and stuff.
Everything goes fine.
That was a woman of 18 who's
just had her first abortion.
Another responded, yes. Friends of mine.
They told me that they had it done and
then you don't feel anything. That was uh,
a 15 when you're a 15 year old girl.
Her first abortion, another respondent.
My cousin had an abortion. She told me
that nothing out of the ordinary happened,
that everything went well. This is a
female age 21 on her second abortion? No,
the responded when I was in school,
a friend of mine had an abortion.
She was fairly young, around 13
old because we in the eighth grade.
What did she tell you?
How did it go?
She told me it went well and
set the anesthetic was fine.
Girls talk about that kind of stuff.
This was a 31 year old woman
on her fourth abortion.
Another respondent.
Have you heard to the question,
have you heard much talk about
abortion? Oh yes. Among girls at school,
they don't use anything.
Meaning they don't use any contraceptive.
So when they get pregnant,
they go to get an abortion.
They talk about it like it's nothing.
It's like drinking a glass of water.
Some people have problems when they
get an abortion, but most people don't.
Almost always the procedure goes fine.
That's a 17 year old girl
after her first abortion.
It's a very interesting
case because while their,
their experience, they're hearing
one thing from the government,
the same thing for the medical community.
But they know lots and lots of people
have had abortion as a common subject and
they're not hearing about any difficulties
from an, or, very rarely are they.
So the government pushing comes to
them and they use contraception.
What's really at 92% of the Cuban women
have used contraception at some time
or another.
And even among adolescent girls who
obviously having a very rich sex life,
cause they're getting
pregnant all the time, um, uh,
84% have used some form of contraception,
but it doesn't mean anything
to them because they're
just as happy with abortion.
So they're not, they're not
worried about getting pregnant.
So they sometimes use contraception.
They sometimes don't.
And there their reports of when they
use it, or almost totally haphazard,
they'll use it for a while,
they'll stop using it,
they'll start again and they change
methods and it doesn't even have anything.
So of course women go through
periods and men to know when their
interrelationship having sex or
just having a lot of casual sex.
And the woman will tell you this.
And the use of contraception did not
correlate at all with periods when the
women were having sex.
So just a total disconnect.
And undoubtedly the reason is that
they're perfectly happy with abortion and
it's a fine backup.
So they don't have to be terribly careful
about using contraception. And in fact,
as much as they're hearing,
uh,
that abortion is no big deal,
uh, they're hearing that,
that the other forms of contraception
are really not very pleasant.
So here's more answers
to survey questions.
I don't like the pill because
extra hormones in a woman's body,
a male age 19 says that woman,
and this is a woman.
No, I don't use any IUD because
my body can't support it.
It falls out of place. So you
have used an Iud in the past? Yes.
I had an Iud two different times
and both times it fell out of place.
I have problems with our yards.
That's a 37 year old woman
on her second abortion.
Iud causes pain to women.
After my first pregnancy
I had an IUD inserted,
but I had to have it removed
because it was causing pain.
I started having problems with my
period and a lot of inflammation.
And when I had sex it was painful.
So I had the IUD removed.
Female Age 35.
Her first abortion.
I had an IUD before I had
her for two years. Uh,
but I had it removed because I
had abnormal menstrual bleeding,
a 42 year old woman, fourth
abortion, no other woman.
Sometimes we'll use protection,
but the condom broke.
You explained these things to
the doctors and they say that,
that this doesn't happen,
but I'm telling you it's not a lie.
Sometimes condoms are bad and they
break some 19 year old girl on, on,
on her third abortion, 88%. Uh,
so at the time of the survey,
88% were practicing contraception at
the time of the survey. And again,
among adolescents,
68% were using kind of at the time
of the survey yet the contraception,
they didn't like it, it wasn't effective
and they were apparently just as happy,
uh, with, with the abortion. Um,
so,
uh,
so it's,
it's,
it's a very interesting thing and this
is repeated in basically all of the East
European countries where again,
they have long experience with abortion
and they don't particularly see any
benefit to contraception.
Now the standard thing that you'll hear
in America from everybody, you know,
again, independent of, of their, you know,
they can be right to life or pro choice.
And the thing is that the idea is,
and I've been sort of saying that here
the idea is to replace abortion with
contra contraception.
That contraception is a better
method of birth control and abortion.
Uh, it's a controversial, but
now it's converse. Actually,
what started me really looking into this,
it was a number of years ago,
I was giving a lecture and I was
saying very overtly that, well,
it's progress when one country and when
contraception replaces abortion. And,
uh, no, it's,
it's not so obvious because I showed
you this one that the safest method is,
uh, is uh, uh, uh, uh,
condoms backed by abortion.
And it's very,
it was very hard to, and so one student
asked me this question about why, why is,
why do you, why you think
that contraception is better
than abortion is a very,
very hard question to
answer. And I, I won't, uh,
won't even try to do this
today. It's, it's a very,
it's a very difficult kind of issue.
So the final thing that I
should tell you is that, uh,
one of the things we worry about is
population growth rate. That abortion, uh,
makes a huge difference in the
global rate of population growth.
As I've told you, this is, you know,
ballpark 75 million increase in the world.
Now,
uh,
if the abortion rate is about
somewhere between 40 and 50 million,
that means that the rate of
world population increase
goes up by three cut by
75% or something because abortion is
such a large fraction of the birth rate,
that if that if abortion disappears
and is not replaced by contraception,
the population growth rate goes crazy.
And so,
uh,
in the world as it is now,
there's probably not any chance
of stabilizing world population,
uh, without abortion.
So, okay. Just on time,
uh, we will continue with
the biology of abortion and,
and some of the history and,
and philosophical considerations
in the next lecture.